I am really close with my
grandfather, he just turned 85.
So when I was thinking about
the type of company that I wanted
to build, and the type of person I
wanted to build for,
I think about my grandpa.
[MUSIC]
I grew up really close with my
grandfather from the time that he
was in his 90s, and
I saw him really struggled to
get the care that he needed.
That motivated me to dive deep and
figure out, how can I start
a company that makes this better.
[MUSIC]
Sarah and
I met at an admitted students event
before Stanford events started.
>> When we were applying to the GSB
independently, each of us wrote our
essays about why we wanted
to start a company in healthcare.
>> We were at a happy hour and
Sarah overheard me say,
>> I'm coming to Stanford because I
want to start a healthcare company.
And I think I ran across the room,
[LAUGH].
We knew pretty quickly that we
wanted to start a company together.
It's very clear to us that we
wanted to build an impact oriented
company that made healthcare better
for older adults.
[MUSIC]
At FairStreet,
we help seniors enroll in the right
health insurance plan, and we
do that by empowering independent
insurance agents with the tools
they need to run their business and
serve more seniors.
>> What we realized after doing
a couple 100 interviews with
seniors all across the country,
is that the universal pain point is
how to navigate the overwhelming
nature of Medicare enrollment.
From there we looked at, well,
who had a really good experience
enrolling in Medicare, and
who didn't.
And the people who had the best
experiences were the ones who
worked with these local
independent agents.
>> So what we did is we went out
and we interviewed hundreds of
independent insurance agents, and
figured out that they lack any kind
of software to run their business.
>> And so that's exactly where we
saw an opportunity.
>> A software that we built is
a solution for
these amazing independent agents to
be able to run their business.
>> The best compliment we've ever
gotten from a senior is saying,
that was easy.
I feel confident I know how to use
my Medicare plan.
I feel like I'm set up for
the right healthcare.
So Stanford teaches us to dream
really big, and changing lives,
organizations, and the world.
I think a lot about our
role in changing organizations.
A big motivator for me personally
in starting a company it's to form
and create an organization that I
would have always wanted to work at
as an employee.
And as two female co-founders
ourselves, it's something that we
think a lot about is how do we
create an inclusive culture
an equitable culture,
a culture where everyone can get to
show up and do the best work of
their life >> Before coming
to the GSB I thought that business
was very strict and very factual.
And at the GSB you learn about how
much emotion and feelings play into
what goes on in a business.
My grandfather would definitely
be proud of FairStreet.
And I think that the thing
you would hope for the most is that
other people have a better
healthcare experience than he did.
Our whole family would have liked
to spend the last years of my
grandfather's life together as
a family, and not trying to wade
through medical bills and
medical decisions.
If he could see other families
having that better experience I'm
sure he would be very proud.
[MUSIC]
>> For our ambition to change the
world, we're just getting started.
Our hope is that if we're
successful, every single
person turning 65 does not have
to worry about their healthcare.
That they're taken care of by
FairStreet and by one of the
amazing agents that we work with,
so that they can have healthcare
for the rest of their life.
My name is Sarah Jacobson,
I'm the Co-Founder and
CEO of FairStreet.
>> My name is Tori Seidenstein, and
I'm the Co-Founder and
CTO of FairStreet.
[MUSIC]